Happy Friday, friends.
I played pickleball this morning for three hours
with the older people at my community center,
and I love them.
I know all their names.
They all know me.
They're so sweet.
I love it when they talk about me and they don't know.
I can hear them talking about me in the sweetest way possible.
And they're such encouragers.
One of my favorite ladies is 86,
and she's a star on the pickleball court,
like, an absolute star.
I love playing with her because she crushes it every single time.
And I heard talking about me today,
she's like, I just love Jen.
Isn't she just the most darling?
I'm like, you're the most darling, Carol.
I love you. I love you.
I thought a whole new community of people in pickleball.
This is your sign to start going to your local community center
and playing pickleball with older people
because they know how to freaking play pickleball.